this is the opportunity to change
everything and everyone thinks just i
want to do exactly what i'm doing
but a little bit more and this is your
opportunity
to completely sell everything start from
scratch start from zero and say
i can do anything i want what do i want
to do
i don't have to keep doing anything that
i was doing before i can completely
change
chris bloody sparks in the building how
are you doing man
fantastic good to be back so good to
have you back on man how's 2020 been
your end
you know it's there's been a lot of
bright spots this year i think
everyone's aware of the craziness and
all that's gone on
but i would then be uh pleasantly
surprised uh how well
i've thrived uh i think the big news was
uh i got engaged realized that
um my partner who uh
some would say i was i was stuck with is
like wow this is amazing we get to spend
all this time together and we're having
a blast
uh and hey if it's so good when things
can't appear so bad uh let's uh let's
take this to the next level
so that was a super silver lining um you
know this this really
made me refocus on priorities
which i think we'll get into
particularly being closer to family so
moving closer so we could spend a lot of
time with our respective families
my just born niece has been incredibly
meaningful
and also just i've been fortunate that
you know the way that i earn a living
the way that i serve the world
both of those were already online based
so i've had lots of
really meaningful and interesting
opportunities
to support entrepreneurs and executives
through all of this turmoil
so i mean all external craziness aside
i think it's been a very cool year you
are one anti-fragile son
aren't you that is the goal
you i mean the world is going to get
weirder it is just going to get weird
it's not going back to normal what
happened this year
was not just like a glitch in the matrix
um weird stuff is going to continue to
occur
and you know my goal personally and how
i try to help clients
is how can you put yourself in a
position
to thrive no matter what the world
throws at you
and i think it's really encapsulated by
that concept
of anti-fragility is while
many systems people organizations
are threatened with hey if things change
a little bit
if the tide rolls out and oh no i have
my pants down
uh you know there any change becomes
bad and becomes a threat but you can
position yourself
with your habits with your relationships
with your learning to be someone who not
only
is does okay when
things get weird you can actually thrive
in those environments because you're
well positioned
you're already surfing before the wave
comes
so yeah i i think this was a
a test and that's what i come back to is
it's all
practice it's all an opportunity to put
the things that we've learned and know
into practice obviously your background
professional
online poker player top in the world and
executive coach to founders and ceos and
all of this stuff
i'm going to guess that the end of the
year is probably a pretty intense time
when it comes to reflecting and planning
yeah i i try to practice what i preach i
think that's
a really big factor
or what i would call a forcing function
to be able to
walk the talk so to say so i try to set
aside a few days
and the at the end of the year to close
the container
on what happened in the previous year
and do what i can
to set myself up for success
particularly as around the holidays
there's less
inbound coming in things slow down
and i like to go against traffic that i
find that hey when everyone else is
taking time off
that's the best time to do the deep work
and something that i've done
the past couple years is i then go
and take the the takeaways from my
annual review
and planning and share them online
which i'll get into later why the the
returns that i've seen from that
and so that that's that's essentially
i'm blocking off about a week
towards the end of the year solely for
that that process
of capture and then turning that into a
post what's your
stance on new year new me
uh i think i think in terms of
continuous small improvements
so you know nothing changes
when january first comes along
versus december 31st but
these cultural milestones arbitrary
as they are the you know your birthday
the end of the year these can serve as
very valuable
checkpoints so i try to treat it as a
checkpoint you know on
paper nothing has changed from one day
to the next but it can be very useful to
have these recurring check-ins to say
what's going on what's next and so
i don't think that i want to try to
change
everything but it's a good opportunity
to check hey
a lot of things change in a year
especially this year
what's changed based on that what makes
sense to move towards next
got you so why do we need to do an end
of year review what are the advantages
so many uh so i would say
the biggest pitch that i would give to
someone who's considering doing this
is life is
better so we perform better
we feel happier more fulfilled whether
that's in our work
or in the people that we love when we
spend more time
in the present and the issue is today
we spend most of our time rehashing the
past
things that we regret things that we
wish we could have done beating
ourselves up for past failures
or in the future things that are
upcoming
stressing out about upcoming deadlines
or
rehearsing conversations that we're
about to have and my just
overall stance is if we can increase the
proportion of time that we spend in the
present
by just a tiny bit we will get more done
we will be happier more fulfilled or
just subjective experience of reality
will be enhanced and so if i
set a tight side time to reflect
and plan to do that thinking about the
past
and the future during a designated time
that means
more of my time i will be able to be
present that'll be in that present
moment
so that's like the overarching idea of
why
reflection and planning is important
annual reviews in particular i think
about every year
as a chapter in my story and so
in my 820
chapter story this 2021
chapter for me chapter 34
is a good opportunity to think as the
writer of that story
what's happening next to the character
what would i like to happen what
tension is likely to emerge what
opportunities are likely to present
themselves
and if i can if i can position myself
and generate some awareness about what's
coming up
i can be ready i can be prepared for
that i can seize those
opportunities and i see it as
i can architect this next chapter of my
story
if i do some outlining of it ahead of
time
um maybe this is a good time to talk
about the four parts of what i think of
a good
annual review and planning process are
before we do that okay
where do most people go wrong when they
try and do review they haven't seen you
they haven't done your worksheet
and they just think i'm gonna have a
crack at this myself what what are the
mistakes that people make
i think i think first i would say that
any is better than none so that's the
biggest mistake
is i'm just gonna keep doing i'm just
gonna keep doing what i was doing and
you know that's insanity doing the same
thing over and over again and expecting
different results so my approach is
any time and intentionality that you
bring to this exercise
is going to have a 10x return on your
time and attention so
first just take it seriously
i think the cultural notion of
a new year's resolution or as you said
the new me
is a good encapsulation of how a lot of
people
go wrong with this is they expect
january 1st to come along and all of a
sudden they're going to become
superhuman
you know going from someone you know
let's say hypothetically
someone who hasn't been exercising
recently
and okay that first you know everyone
knows those first two weeks at the gym
are the worst two weeks to go to the gym
because all of a sudden everyone thinks
they're gonna be exercising for an hour
a day
and so someone tries to go from zero
to sixty with nothing to sustain them
except for willpower and the temporary
motivation of this year is different
and we all know what happens to those
people after the first couple weeks
of the year they can't sustain that
sprint forever
and so i think that's the second thing
to
to consider is rather than everything is
going to change and i'm going to put
this
huge unsustainable goal in front of
myself
thinking about what is that next step
that i can take to create some forward
momentum i don't need to change
everything at once but generally where
am i heading
so in my health and my relationships and
my career
where is that next north star i'd like
to direct my attention to
and just what is that next step on the
path i think
that that consistency and that
continuous improvement
that's what i call a feedback loop right
it feeds on itself
every improvement become plants the
seeds
for the next improvement and so i think
that's the second thing to highlight or
a lot of people go wrong
is they set the bar so high for
themselves it's unrealistic it's
unsustainable
and i think the the final thing that i
would mention here
is this is the opportunity to
change everything so i
i think when i see a lot of people's
results of their goals
it was oh i made i made 50
000 this year next year i want to make
60
000 or i had 50 clients this year next
year i want to have 60 clients
or i can bench press 300 pounds now i
want to bench press
350 pounds and everyone thinks just i
want to do exactly what i'm doing
but a little bit more and this is your
opportunity
to completely sell everything
start from scratch start from zero and
say
i can do anything i want what do i want
to do
i don't have to keep doing anything that
i was doing before i can completely
change and so everyone is like oh
i'm going to is it this path all the way
over here or is it this path
all the way over here and no there's
always a middle path
that someone isn't considering and so
this is your
opportunity say don't try to do
more it's not what i'm doing now but
just more of it
is what do you want what would you like
to be doing
and giving yourself permission to think
outside the box to think about things
maybe that haven't been considered
that's why i said it's nice to have this
space
for possibility because most of the year
we want to be spending our time in the
present
focused sprinting forward and now is
your
time to just question everything and
that is so refreshing
yeah the um opportunity to assess our
fundamentals as you say there the
explore before you exploit
kind of paradigm is so rare
and you know everyone this year even
though
probably the amount of stuff that we've
been able to do has gone down
the urgent has still beaten the
important for the most part
tasks that are in front of you the email
that needs sorting that load of washing
that's got to be taken out before it
gets musky you know all that sort of
stuff
um people often can spend their entire
lives and i'm realizing this now
i can i could literally spend the rest
of my life
from 32 years old until the day i die
just dealing with urgent
and never doing important and i'd always
feel busy and it would give me the
sensation of being busy and being
productive
but at the end the actual amount of
movement ground that i'd covered
would be very little also i was away in
dubai recently for about three and a
half weeks and while i was out there i
met
millionaires billionaires founders ceos
endurance athletes youtubers podcasters
stephen bartlett the ceo that founded
social chain from diary of a ceo
like literally guys that have such huge
broad scope vision and it just blew my
world view apart
i thought that i had a good idea of the
sort of progression that i was able to
predict oh well i can do
you know grow the show by this and i'd
start this business and oh i get a
membership site and
this that any other and then i went and
spoke to steve over dinner
and he said i was talking about how's
podcasting going who you've got oh i've
got eddie hearn the boxing promoter
coming out oh cool i've got eddie hearn
coming on soon that'll be sweet there's
nothing i'm thinking
and we're on the same path he's just a
little bit sort of
further along with a bigger pair of
shoes on than i am and then i started
talking about how he's monetizing
and he was like oh yeah well huel
approached me because the ceo loves my
podcast
and originally i think they might just
wanted to sponsor it
but then we turned the deal around and
now i'm on the board i'm gonna take them
to ipo
i've been given equity in the business
i'm gonna get them to ipo and then i'm
gonna exit
and i was like okay yeah no i'm playing
checkers and you're playing chess
like this is a total fundamental
different world view that we have over
what is achievable
and i think what you're talking about
there that step back
reconsider what are the possibilities
that i can do
like full nothing uncover what's
underneath the rug what's in that
cupboard over there
absolutely everything so yeah i am it
resonates a lot with what i've learned
especially
recently so the the framework take us
through the framework
yeah i like what you said there around
this is an opportunity to expand your
sense of the possible
and so if you're thinking about how do i
increase my conversion rate just for my
email signups
you're probably doing it wrong this is
you can think a little bit bigger than
that give yourself some temporary
permission
um so i'm adapting my format a little
bit
this year i will say the the the
format that i've used the past few years
is available
online i'm going to post that in the uh
the show notes
so we'll put that link in there this
year
the way that i'm going about it it's
going to have four
parts and so the four parts are
reflection vision planning
implementation and so i'm going to do
just a quick walk through of each of
those parts
and so first reflection this is looking
backwards
at the previous year and the classic two
questions
what went well what didn't go so well
and obviously the follow-up to
those what can i take away from that
what did i
learn and so this is where i'm looking
at each area of my life
so that i think the three basic pillars
that everyone has
career health relationships and you can
break those down
for yourself depending upon you know
need
desire motivation so for example for
career
i'd be looking at forcing function i'd
be looking at poker i'm doing some
investing so i'm looking at my investing
maybe with health if you play a sport
you want to break out diet or exercise
or sleep
relationships for me i'm looking at my
relationship with my partner
relationship with my family relationship
with my friends
so you this is fractal you can go down
to any level
and so with reflection i'm trying to
pull up
anything that happened something that
was something that
i learned something that was unexpected
something that changed along the year
that i didn't expect from the beginning
all of these things are helping me to
identify
what's going on what conditions work for
me
what efforts that i did this year led me
towards my goals
just anything that i can use as fuel
for this next year things that i can
draw upon whether that's celebrating
wins oh that was awesome i want to do
more of that
or oh i thought i was going to do that
but i didn't even start
or oh i tried that and it went horribly
let's uncover
everything that happened with that and
what how can we avoid
paying tuition for those same mistakes
twice
because if we really bring up those
lessons
hey that's incredibly efficient that
we're not going to
do it that way again or that worked
let's remember that next time when we're
in that same spot
and so i set about 90 minutes aside 45
for things that went well 45 for the
things
that didn't go so well the second part
go ahead uh i just wondered there how
are you
defining or how are you finding the
things that you want to focus on
is it like an objective metric like i
had this much
sex this year i had this much revenue
this year
you know like people could drown
themselves in
just high accolades are there any ways
that you try and
pinpoint is it just anything that kind
of arises into consciousness the good
[ __ ] sticks sort of
yeah i think it's very possible to drown
in details and to turn this
into a accounting exercise retrospective
diamond um
yeah so i mean the first way is within
the each area i'm setting a timer and my
goal is to just
keep my pencil moving until the timer
goes
off and so anything and everything no
editing myself i'm not trying to create
some sort of narrative i'm not
patting myself on the back anything that
comes up
and so if i have numbers handy that's
awesome
i don't i don't do any of this near a
computer so if it requires me looking
something up
i'll just make a guess or i'll say hey
how that felt
or hey here are some wins that came from
it it's super for me it's super
subjective
um early in the year i have some
objective metrics to grounded upon
um after i've done the the brain dump
i might check some of my monthly reviews
to see hey is there anything that i
forgot about because a year's a long
time but
yeah essentially whatever it comes to
consciousness
um trying to you know swim as deep in
the water as i can
what's the reason for doing it analog
rather than digital
uh because i'm a total luddite and i
think that computers
are a gateway to distraction
that is a very it's a very good joking
half serious
uh i think that i think that our tools
shape us in a number of ways
and i i for me i i like this process to
be a little bit
messy and i'm really big on trying to
unplug
and get away from my current context so
this is probably a good time
to note as far as logistical stuff uh
don't do this at your desk don't do this
in the place that you spend a lot of
your time where
your context in a lot of ways shapes
your thinking
and so i try to get as far from my desk
as possible um if you're lucky enough to
live in the southern hemisphere
hey like go put a blanket down on the
beach or in the woods
um if you're you know like us you're
stuck and it's super cold
and you have the ability i like to run
an airbnb
for a couple days you know get a cabin
in the woods
and you know ideally there's no internet
there or i unplug the internet
and just try to get away from my normal
way of thinking and doing things
as possible if it's not possible for you
to
leave your home your apartment um
pick a new space create a special space
like a new chair in a new area that you
don't work
make it inspiring make it make it a
place that that's reflective
of the intentionality you're bringing to
the exercise but yeah i i think that's a
really big part
of getting the maximum out of this
exercise is to get away from your normal
way of being
that pattern interrupts interesting
really interesting i'm a big fan i'm
we could go down this rabbit hole
forever but my newsletter that's going
out this week
is all about the pattern interrupt that
i had while i was in dubai
okay so we've got um what went well and
what went badly
from the last year family or
relationships
career and what was the final one health
health cool what next
so we've generated all of this fuel all
these things that learned
so we're a little bit inspired and we're
a little bit disgusted and we're going
to take that
and we're going to convert it into this
next step
which is vision and at a high level
vision is what do we want and
what another the overall question is
what does next year
look like and so this is a visualization
in the present we're not saying here's
what i'm going to do it's like
here's what next year looks like and
trying to paint a picture
of what we want and so revisiting all of
these areas
what do i want my health to be like what
do i want my career to look like
what's a typical day of work what's a
typical day
with my partner and creating a picture
of that and the end game of this
is generating creative tension
and so with the reflection we have this
picture of current reality and now we
have this vision of
here's what reality could be and so
like a rubber band there's this tension
and well now i know where i am
and now i know where i want to be and
it's very obvious the differences
between these two pictures and so one of
two things
needs to change right nature abhors a
vacuum either
i need to bring this vision closer into
reality
you know lower the bar for myself maybe
something that's a little bit more
realistic based on what's going on now
and or i take my cur where i currently
am and i
push it into alignment with where i want
things to be
and so i find this is a really valuable
second part of this that's often skipped
and that in the past that would skip
is what do i want what are things going
to look like
um because this is what allows me to
determine
what goals do i need to have in order to
bring this vision into reality
that's cool man the differential i think
jordan peterson's got his
um future authoring and past authoring
and present authoring
program and he uses precisely the same
thing that you create the tension
between the two
so we've got our reflection we've got
vision
i forgot the next one what's the next
one so halfway home
um vision i set aside 60 minutes um and
again
this is lots of writing no judgment keep
the pen
moving anything is possible type
thinking
and so i generally recommend hey that's
that's a lot of brain work we're talking
only two and a half hours so obviously
someone has the time
but it's gonna you're gonna feel pretty
drained afterwards and so this is where
i recommend
if you can end for the day and just like
f off for the rest of the day go run
around
and play with flowers you know go for
you know
ride your bike uh hang out with your
family
read some books just like do something
that is completely non-work completely
unrelated just recharge yourself
and it's like letting all of this sit
you wanna you wanna sleep on it because
things are going to come up in the
interim
now that you've opened these loops
you'll start to identify
connections and so this is a great place
for a productive break
where you do anything that's not
productive
um okay day two and so this is
this is all right now i know what
happened now i know what i want
what the hell am i gonna do to make this
happen and so part three
is planning and so this is this is part
of the template which i'm going to share
with
modern wisdom crew you're looking at
these areas that you identified
in the reflection and you're picking one
goal
just one everyone wants to pick multiple
one goal
that you're going to shoot for in the
next year that north star
and so the framing here is if you could
only achieve
one thing in your health if you only
achieve one thing in your relationships
you only achieve one thing in your
career what would that
be and really really defining that
so how will you know if you've achieved
it why is it important to you
what would it look like if it was
achieved what does that unlock
you know let's say that you've achieved
enlightenment
what's next what does that get you right
thinking about
what do you want if you can only pick
one thing and said a lot of life
is reconciling with these trade-offs and
so assume you can only get one thing and
choose wisely
don't assign yourself more than you can
chew hey worst case scenario you achieve
your big goal
by month six you have permission to pick
a second one
no big deal so this is like each area of
my life and so i break mine down a
little bit
thinking about what's my one goal in
this area
and so once i've really really defined
that it's clear what it looks like
someone else who's an objective
third-party observer say yes chris you
did that
or no chris you're kidding yourself i'm
going to start to break that goal down
into milestones
and so hypothetically if i wanted to
achieve this goal
right on december 31st 2021 i would
break this down to okay
end of q1 end of q2 end of q3 here's
where i need to be
in order to know if i'm on track towards
this goal or off track towards this goal
and so let's say you know just stop top
my head
maybe my goal for next year is to be
exercising for an hour every day
well i'm not going to start this on day
one it might be all right end of q1
i want to be exercising one day a week
every week without fail and then at q2
sorry i want to be exercising
two times a week every week without fail
right not missing a single one
q3 all right only exercising four times
a week or every other day whatever it is
and so building up slowly
and so by breaking down these milestones
along the year it allows me to course
correct if i'm behind
all right something's got to change here
if i'm ahead
maybe i can raise the bar for myself a
little bit
the and then the final step
just before that um your goal there that
you've just chosen i'm aware is just a
hypothetical but you've chosen a process
goal
as the outcome goal so what you want is
to be able to get to a point where you
are able to do a process and that
process is your goal
is that something that you would tend to
get people to focus on
would you rather people focus on not
saying so for me next year with the
podcast
or sort of the channel overall would it
be
more optimal for me to say i want to hit
500 000 subscribers on youtube by
december 31st 2021
or would you say i want to be publishing
regularly one bespoke youtube video
per week by the first of december the
31st of december 2021
you know in terms of guidance i think
typically before
james clearer came along everybody
thought in terms of outcome goals
but as we know outcomes are lagging
measures behind the lead measures which
are our habits and our behaviors on a
daily basis
how do we how do we fit all of that
together i know that
like actual tacit goals the 100k play
button that you get for youtube
subscribers or whatever
is a nice motivator um and that kind of
helps to get us moving
but also the daily uh challenges that
what makes the difference is the habits
how how do we kind of
marry those two excellent question and
if you don't mind i'm going to use you
as a guinea pig example
the short short answer is both
and so the 500 000 subscribers
this is part of the vision so having
that outcome in mind right what do i
want
and i think that you work backwards from
there
but again a lot of people let themselves
off the hook
on this and so let's use that example
it's all right next year at the end of
the year
i want to have 500 000 subscribers
why why is that important to you what
does that achieve for you
okay now you have 500 000 subscribers
i'm handing them to you
on a silver platter will you take them
like will you take these subscribers
from me
now that you have these subscribers what
next what do you do
um what you know what is that change for
you what's different
um this is all part of that vision as
far as what you want
and so clarifying that and you can say
sometimes
it's oh well i want you know i'm gonna
just project on you these are not things
that chris has told me before
well 500 000 subscribers allows me to
get any guests that i want in the world
to come on the show
or 500 000 subscribers allows me to
maximize
that impact that's the magic number that
i've identified that
hey if i have this memory people i know
lots of people are going to hear me i
create some virality whatever it is
well you're like well that's interesting
well let's say that that
that desired outcome is i want to be
able to get any person on the planet to
come on the modern wisdom show
it's like well is there anything else
you could do that might be a little bit
easier
a little bit more direct towards that
goal and so
like once you have that vision you can
think about are there
any other paths to the top of the
mountain and that's
the planning part is all right now
that we have this vision this north star
in place
which path do i want to take and this is
very much the journey or the input
part of okay well i've decided that 500
000 subscribers
is the goal and now well if i record
this many episodes per per month
and i you know send those episodes to
these
20 influencers uh after every episode
right you break that down into
actionable steps that it's obvious
whether you did it or you didn't
and it brings it back into your own
control
i think the whole notion of a smart goal
is super overplayed but way
underutilized
there's a lot of power and just making
things specific
actionable and measurable and so that
what that
i always start with what do i want but
then i bring that into
what do i have control over what can i
do
what's something that i can track
progress towards so yeah
both and i understand yeah you can't i
can't control whether or not we hit
half a million subs i can't control
whether or not i can
deadlift 280 kilos this time next year
but i can control whether or not i stick
to my program and stick to my diet and
continue to turn up in the gym and
progressively overload and regularly
check in and do my rehab and all the
rest of it
and over time it's what are the things
that i can do that give me the best
chance of achieving the goal that i have
set
one hundred percent you take a goal
which is
way out into the future and you turn it
into something that you can
feel satisfaction for moving making
progress on
on a weekly or even a daily level and
that's
critical for taking action is to reduce
that delay
right if it's just hey i want to look
good
in my wedding dress or my suit in nine
months
that doesn't really get me all that
motivated to not have an ice cream today
but if it becomes okay well nine months
down the line i've worked backwards okay
at month one that means
i need to be exercising and at least
tracking my macros at somewhat
or maybe i have one less dessert per
week but something that
in the present is connected to these
future goals
but gives me that satisfaction and
reinforcement that i'm making
progress so the goal setting we're
picking within
the three areas that we've got that's
it we're not breaking that down yet is
that part of implementation
so we're breaking those down into
milestones okay
so you know here's here's along the way
the the implementation part this is the
final
i think this is another part that a lot
of people skip all right it's okay
yes i decided that next year is the year
that i'm gonna eat paleo and all right
i'm just it's just gonna happen it's
gonna be like magic
well now is when we're the most
motivated
that we're ever going to be to become
paleo
and so this is like we set time aside
now
to do something about it to take some
form of action
and so i set an hour aside at the end is
each one of these goals i have some
i have to do something immediately to
put it into practice
and that the power of this is that i
take something from
i'm going to do this to i'm doing it
so let's say my goal next year is to
write a book uh all right well i want to
start writing the book
the day that i decide that i'm going to
write a book even if it is
okay the title of my book is 2021 the
best year ever
subtitle this is gonna be a great year
just like doing
anything that has that verb change to
now
it is underway because it's really
powerful because
the temptation with the goals is like
pat ourselves on the back
great we've done it we're going to go
ahead and you know i don't think
something like
buying a gym membership and saying great
now i'm in shape
is the best thing but you gotta take
that first step so you might as well do
it now
um so this is this is a part that i
think is skipped a lot with these
this planning exercise is like great you
know what you're going to do
do one tiny thing to take action towards
it
so for each of the different areas that
we've got we're going to take action
the messiest one that i can see here is
the relationships one
it's pretty difficult to objectively
metric and quantify like you know let's
say let's say that
by the end of 2021 i want to be in a
long-term committed relationship
um mum don't get into don't don't get
excited there's not wedding about
anything
um i want to be in a committed
relationship by the end of 2021
let's say like you know what's the step
that i
download tinder today you know like make
sure that the hinge profile's being
updated
you understand that i think the the
relationships one's probably
i won't have a better relationship with
my parents brother sister
housemates whatever it might be have you
got any ways that you can kind of cut
through the noise of that
so let's use the first one that's a
common one i hear
is i want to be in a long-term committed
relationship and as everyone knows
there's a lot of this that's in your
control and a lot of it that's out of
your control
unfortunately we can't make someone fall
in love with us
as much as pickup artists would like to
have you believe that
i think that becoming someone
who your dream person
wants to be in a relationship with is
your best thing towards becoming
someone who's in a long-term
relationship right it starts with
working
on yourself and so this is a very good
opportunity both in so primarily in the
vision section
of who is this person
what qualities do they have and what do
they
value how do we spend time together
uh all these types of things having a
clear picture
of what you're looking for and so when
cupid hits you with your arrow you can
recognize
this person perhaps you know what you're
looking for but also
this with the reflection hey how did
things go with dating this year
were you going on dates were you sending
messages
um if the how did those dates go were
you know
were you shiverless were you a dick uh
were you kind were you
you know were you going on dates with
people who looked good on profiles but
obviously
weren't compatible look back to hey
you've probably tried this before
what worked what didn't work let's not
make those same mistakes
over and over again and i think with the
planning
personally with dating um you know said
i don't know a lot of people meet
their significant others on dating sites
i don't think that's the most direct
path
i think the most direct path is who are
those key relationships who know
people who i would like to date and
perhaps they might want to
set up some form of an introduction and
so
i'm thinking about who are those three
people who might know someone and i'm
gonna send them a message
right now and let's like let's line a
couple things up
and and so things that you can quantify
right being careful on some of these
right if you if you over optimize
towards
like number of dates right you're going
to go you're going to waste your time on
a lot of
a lot of poor dates um but you know it's
like a good thing to check in on is
what am i doing both to
say generate some serendipity surface
area right i'm meeting new people
i'm being open that hey every person
that i meet
who i'm somewhat attracted to i'm gonna
be in this frame of
is this a person that i'd like to spend
more time with
um you know this is a good i like to say
you know hang before you bang
like but this is a good like is this
someone who i like spending time with
that's a good it's a good question to
start with
um and then thinking about yourself what
can
i be doing to become the type of person
that this person would like to date um
and
i don't know this maybe this is just you
know
apocryphal but my perception and my
observation
is if someone becomes someone
who you we like ourselves right
we're confident because we're healthy
we're present when we're in a
conversation with someone
we're working towards our vision uh
whether that's in our business
or the service or mission that on the
world you're happy
that becoming someone who's dateable
miraculously
find someone to date um so yeah
i think that's kind of a two-prong
approach that i would take you're using
an
affiliate model to get new dates when
you're dating
most direct path that hey
going on a dating site there's lots of
things the problem is
there's so much to unpack here the
problem is so much of our cognitive
machinery
is dedicated towards reassuring
ourselves that we're doing a great job
it's like awesome christopher you know
and i said like my alter ego awesome
christopher
you sent 20 messages this week you're
doing great
and hey you went on 10 dates with people
who
you know they love celebrity gossip and
you've never watched television in your
life
awesome job you're gonna find the one
that
next day right and it's very easy to
justify
what we're already doing and you know
scrolling through tinder is obvious it's
super easy it doesn't require a lot of
effort it's a lot of it's very passive
but it feels productive hey we're doing
something
and usually the most direct path
the fastest way to achieve our goals
is really uncomfortable asking for help
is really uncomfortable but just think
about context
is it more likely that you were going to
find your person
through like a random heap that the
algorithm is serving you
or through someone who knows you
incredibly well
and knows another person incredibly well
and can make a very
warm introduction that makes you look
really good
where the other person feels safe and
open
which of those is more likely to be
successful yes it's going to be a little
bit uncomfortable
but certainly you're going to have to go
on fewer of those
dates to get something going than the
other way around
and so that's a good question to ask is
are you willing to be a little bit
uncomfortable
i love it man internet marketers out
there just thinking in their heads about
warm leads versus cold leads right now
yeah so what i've done is i'm kind of
retargeting it's sort of on an affiliate
model and there's the front end of the
funnel's actually been
they've got a referral code and they've
come through onto this different landing
page
so okay so that's the the four steps is
there anything else it's a good lens
it's a good lens to think about things
right hey it's like
something that works for you in another
part of your life
right say i'm really good at marketing
how could i apply
marketing to this other part of my life
it's like it's crazy that i see
someone who is just
absolute outlier in one area of their
life completely has one area of their
life
solved and then in another area just
completely wings it
it's like this thing that's working for
you over here have you tried that
over here it's it's it's surprising how
often that works
taking those mental models and applying
them elsewhere because as we've
identified today the principles are the
same you have large goal broken down
into sub tasks broken down into smaller
tasks broken down into daily actions
and that slowly gets you to where you
want to be but yeah the number of
business people who are massively out of
shape or the number of good athletes
who've got [ __ ] relationships or the
number of people that are happily
married but their careers going down the
pan
like you know these things don't happen
by accident so we've got the we got the
framework is there anything else to say
about the framework there
no i think that's good um i think
you know viewers will see the the
template
i think the questions lay it out a lot
of this is just
asking yourself questions attacking the
problem from different angles
and listening for answers and so the
more questions you ask the more angles
you approach things from
the more likely you are to elevate
something that you might have
missed and hey i just taking it
seriously the the process that i laid
out
um you know for me takes about five
hours
um you know it's fractal if you have one
hour spend one hour
but the idea is here hey i dedicate
one full day or two full days to this
maybe i increase my chances of achieving
this stuff
by a hundred percent next year because i
avoid making a bunch of mistakes
or i get started in february instead of
october
like it's worth investing the time now
to figure this stuff out because hey
this year when that's when things kick
off i want to be sprinting
i don't want to be sitting in april
having an existential crisis and being
what do i want to do with my life
now is the time for that crisis let's
get out of the way doing it again
yeah i mean the time as well between
christmas and new year is such a
like dead men zone in in any case what's
going on
nothing you finishing off the
confectionary
celebrations sharing box of sweets and
kind of getting a little bit bored of
being with your family and the dogs
farted and you know like
you you probably but you also don't want
to go back to work right
and i think everyone it might just be me
but everybody gets reflective towards
the back end of the year we
these stake posts in the ground we think
okay
i was here probably in the same place
mum and dad's house
boyfriend's house girlfriend's house
whatever family house with the kids
i'm in the same place as i was this time
last year
what's different perhaps the location's
the same but what else has changed
and i think yeah it's a natural run-on
it doesn't surprise me that there is
such a thing as new year's resolutions
it's kind of like
if there wasn't a name for it people
would come up with one um
how can people stay motivated 80 of new
year's resolutions fail
what's the way that we don't just get to
the february slump
and everything drops off
the way to stay motivated is to not need
motivation
if you need motivation to succeed
you're not going to succeed uh
i think motivation is
is very flighty uh if you personify
motivation uh they're very wispy they're
hard to
hard to pin down and so my
goal with this exercise is to eliminate
the need for motivation throughout the
year assume
that there will be long periods yes it
happens for me
all the time as well where i don't want
to do
anything towards my goals and i'm super
unmotivated
how can i set up conditions that i make
motivation
irrelevant that i can't help but slip
and fall and stumble into making some
form of progress towards my goals
how can i make what i want to do easier
so that's the really key part of that
implementation
at the end is what can i do now to start
moving to already start making progress
and to make progress throughout the year
easier and you know again you notice
that i'm eating my own dog food and
we're like oh my god chris just said
spend six hours looking at my life and
he wants me to do more
i wonder if he checked in at regular
intervals
say every three months or every month
even if it's just asking yourself
questions like you said hey
i was sitting in the same chair in a
month ago what's different from the last
month
or what's changed what's working these
types of questions
if you keep asking yourself the same
questions you're going to want to give
yourself different answers
and so that's what i refer to as the
improvement loop
and so you have the three parts it's
reflection
execution and planning and so the faster
that you're going through this loop
the faster you will make progress and so
that that's essentially what i recommend
is hey
this is this is the super 10 000 foot
view
like really stepping back but if you
don't come back to these questions
throughout the year you're going to
forget about the answers
and so hey return to them come back to
your responses read them over remind
yourself of why you're doing what you're
doing because it's easy to forget
and just keep thinking about hey what
can i do now
to move myself forward a few inches
towards this vision
um it's really a marathon and not a
sprint
what's the cadence that you do that on
personally do you do
90 days uh
my monthly review is the big one um
where i spend a couple hours every month
usually on a sunday
with a nice pot of tea uh just going
through all the areas of my life
and saying hey what's going on um this
is where i usually pull in a little bit
more data
so i have things to draw upon but
essentially this is just my check in
what's what's
i have a green yellow red system so
green
awesome keep it up you're doing great
don't change a thing
um yellow all right like at least you're
at least you're not like completely
going backwards right you're making some
progress like you know caution like you
probably could be doing better
think about maybe ways to accelerate red
you know get your ish together
like you haven't done you haven't done
anything um assume that if you don't
change anything nothing's going to
change
yeah that like zooming in on those red
it's like all right
i don't want to put red down two months
in a row what can i do to change that
quarterly level is a little bit more
it's like hey do i want to change those
goals at all it's like
maybe that annual goal i achieved it in
quarter one or i need a new goal
or maybe this annual goal of write a
book uh wow like i've experienced this
before writing a book in a year is like
pretty impossible maybe the end of the
year is like all right have a
have a rough draft of the book that's
like a good it's a good opportunity to
scale up or back those goals
got you so the monthly is a check-in on
cemented goals and the quarterly is
allowing for the optionality to sort of
switch those up while still optimizing
for us to stay on one path
i like that there's um a few sort of
other questions that have been good
prompts for me
um asking myself what would have had to
have happened by the end of this year
for me to look back on this year and
consider it a success
um helps i think to frame that might
even be one of yours
um i made like a this time last year i
made the
ultimate collaboration of all of your
stuff on the internet
it was like your existing experiment
without limits book that i got a hold of
plus then like whatever the original
first draft of that that's still
floating around on medium was
and then something else and there was
like some prompts that i loved that had
gone and some other ones that were still
there
so yeah i sort of found myself being
very playful with that other stuff that
i think would be useful for everyone to
remember
is that the the james clearism i would
imagine most people
fail at the new year's resolutions by
trying to do too much too soon
because we just desire that dopamine hit
of um
so i i've managed to achieve 25 of the
movement toward my one rep max deadlift
i wanted to get by the end of the year
within the first two weeks like yeah
maybe you're gonna [ __ ] your [ __ ] up by
the end of the month
and then you you injured and then you
can do nothing for the next six months
after that
if we set ourselves an appropriate goal
which i guess comes back to the explore
before you exploit paradigm
you will be able to make progress i know
you're a big fan of direction over speed
as well that
as long as you are moving in perfectly
the right direction no matter how slow
you're going
you are always getting closer and closer
toward the end state that you want to be
in
and also the bill gates quote i think
it's most people overestimate what they
can achieve in one year and
underestimate what they can achieve in
five
it just shows that we tend to have a big
blind spot for how
effective compounding can be which
probably not
not all that surprising um but yeah
those are
those are some really good prompts man
i'm looking forward to can i
add a uh oh yeah to one of those yeah
um i agree i think people think far too
much
about speed and efficiency rather than
direction
so thinking about this logically
the best way to waste time imagine
yourself sprinting as fast as you can
faster than you've ever run in your life
but you're going in the opposite
direction
so the better that you do the farther
you get away from where you want to go
and what a great way to just waste your
time
and sorry for being dramatic but your
life to sprint as fast as you can
towards things that you don't actually
want so isn't it worth taking a few
minutes to think about
hey where are you going maybe you know
maybe a map will help you get there
but i do think a danger that i do see
with achiever types with this oh
i need to know exactly where i'm going i
like i need to figure that i need to
figure out exactly what my business
looks like
before i quit my job or i need to know
exactly what my habits are before i
start doing them
is rather like have a general idea
think about all your goals as a rough
draft that are written in pencil that
you can erase and change anytime
it's not the vision it's the power of
the vision
it's not what your vision is it's what
your vision does
it gives you something to head towards
and i think that skill
is to course correct continually
is you're heading in the right general
direction
and you're always aware of opportunities
either to go more directly to where you
want to go
or oh i need to be going northeast and
i'm actually going
northwest all right i'm going to start
to tilt myself a little bit in this
direction
so yeah i just want to make that that
clear up front is you don't need to have
a perfect vision in order to start
moving
forward bro i didn't do
my 2019 new year's resolutions
so like two years ago i didn't do those
until i'd finally finished atomic habits
which ended up being halfway through
february
i was like no no no because it was still
it was still incredibly useful right
it was super bad it was super useful but
i'd been too
focused on having my direction compass
perfectly aligned i was like nah
i'm gonna wait because maybe i could
optimize for a little bit more of this
and i'm like hang on like
ten percent of the year's gone ten
percent of the year has gone by the time
that i've actually done this i could
have done some of it and then updated as
i went
um yeah man it's
it's an interesting time for this sort
of stuff and i hope that it's really
prompted people
i also like i'm gonna guess the reason
that you've put a time limit
on this is to stop people from wallowing
and obsessing too much within that
it's like oh [ __ ] i've got to
parkinson's law this year i only have
90 minutes to do this particular section
i uh
right that'll do that's close enough
like i'm i'm working hard
yeah it serves two purposes and so
people see this procrastination all the
time
is you know you can't get yourself to
get started set a timer for five minutes
and work until that five minutes is up
at least you get at least you're doing
something
and so first like you set that timer um
say okay i'm gonna think about my goals
in this area for the next 15 minutes
until the timer goes off
a lot of people are like okay great 30
seconds and i know what i'm doing for
the next year
i'm not going to spend another 10
minutes thinking about what i'm going to
do all of next year no that's that's
that's not that's not something i need
to do right now it forces someone
to go a little bit deeper the first
answer is usually not the right answer
let's think about other ways to approach
it let's be let's let's think
let's like widen our vision a little bit
so it forces someone to actually use all
that time
keep the pen moving but also said it's
very easy to rabbit hole
on this type of stuff and to go beyond
the point of diminishing marginal
returns
so you set a timer you set a limit it's
like all right i only have this amount
of time
to figure it out you know secret like
you could change it later if you really
want to
but you need some sort of answer in
order to close that container and move
on so i think it works on both sides
i like it any final thoughts about end
of year review planning for the
next year or anything that you need to
add in
i always like to stay with things like
this
don't let the perfect be the enemy of
the good
if this is your first time doing
something like this
anything that you're going to do is
going to be valuable it doesn't need to
be a perfect process
you don't need to spend a ton of time
but to just take it seriously and see
what comes out of it right you're gonna
be living
knock on wood multiple years you'll have
multiple shots at this
to improve so do what you can take the
time to look backwards so think about
what you want to look forwards do
something to put that into motion
and hey it can be messy but you know
just just take it seriously
and do it um and i also say hey i have
the brilliant idea
you know how much i love forcing
functions given the name
of my company i bet between the two of
us
it would be a really valuable forcing
function as well as pretty
illustrative for some viewers if
after we go through this process maybe
we hop on
for those of you guys who are listening
i have one of these conversation series
as well
inspired by by chris where i have guests
on and we do conversations like this
i say we hop on one shower and we talk
about
what came out of this annual review and
planning
so we'll get some public accountability
but we'll kind of allow us to
maybe you know demystify some of this
open up the curtain and say hey what
this actually looks like
behind the scenes you're making that
sound you're making me put my money
where my mouth is now aren't you
it's it's it works perfect man uh what's
the url people want to go and check out
this
worksheet that they can move through
everything what's the url that they need
to go to
sure yeah a few places that i would
point people to
so my company where we work with
executives investors founders is forcing
function
lots of great resources there a couple
places i'd point you to
the annual review template which i
discussed with chris today
you can find that at forcingfunction.com
modern wisdom we're going to put that up
there as free to download for anyone
who's listening to this episode
a couple other places you might want to
check out um
personallyfunction.com workbook the
workbook that chris mentioned earlier
it's my distillation 100 pages of all
the best things that i've seen
to set yourself up for success in
particular
chapter one goals what are the prompts
that you need to do
to discover what you want out of life
what you want to achieve
um those are the ones that i found to
work the best that's also free to
download
a couple other things that i'm really
excited about uh
this is the first time i mentioned it
publicly we're about to release the
forcing function
library so my
favorite studies books articles
resources
on productivity categorized by topic
so there's a special section for
planning and reviews
and you can see all the places where the
things that i talk about
originated my favorite things that i've
found
wandering around the internet for some
of these topics so that's forcing
function library forcingfunction.com
library we have our performance
assessment hey maybe you want some
guidance
on what is the best place for you to get
started in the new year
all these things that could improve what
helped me the most this is our free quiz
to help illuminate your biggest
opportunity in the new year
that's forcingfunction.com assessment
and finally last one i promise
uh we started a program this year
which i was incredibly excited about
where
you know for the past few years i've
only been working one-on-one
with about a dozen executives per year
and so i unfortunately my impact was
limited and for the first time we
started a group coaching program
called team performance training we ran
the first cohort
in september uh it was a great success
um you could see some of the results
that
people had on the page really blew me
away and based on that we're excited to
announce that we'll be running it again
in february and so we're opening up
applications for that
in january so you can check that out on
our website as well if you want to get
notified when those applications are
open
that's forcingfunction.com team training
um you know that's all for me i always
like to think of these conversations as
the beginning of a conversation
um you know chris as you said it's been
a year now i've forced you we're gonna
have to do this again in a month you're
gonna have to see me again
um if any of you guys you know had
questions
something you that i said today
resonated something that we said
that you completely disagree with please
let us know
um you can get a hold of me on twitter
as well my handle is at sparks remarks
dude so good i have to give another
credit to the experiment without limits
which is slash workbook right on your
website
that thing is a magnum opus
of productivity like i've said it to
people before it should be a thousand
pounds
like the fact that you're giving it you
give that away for free is the most
ridiculous thing and then i remember as
well it was you
that introduced me to meditations on
molok
by scott alexander from slate star codex
so i went through your
um my favorite articles from around the
internet which i'm going to guess will
get ported across into this new library
thing
and holy [ __ ] man if you didn't infect
me with the scott alexander bug
when i read that thing i was like what
on earth is what it was it was crazy so
yeah um
you're an underground hero of this stuff
man i know that everyone else who's part
of this space absolutely adores the work
you do and long may it continue
thank you for coming on i'm sure that
everyone's taken just so much away from
this if you do end up doing your end of
your review
and it follows this format just feel
free to tag us wherever you follow us
um that's it man i guess we're gonna
have to we're gonna have to loot back in
early january now and talk about all the
ridiculous plans and my
my innermost fears and dreams for the
next year
i can't wait peace cheers
you